por aquí tenemos la imagen de una
persona promedio mide un poco menos de 2
metros ahora la persona es la unidad de
vida más grande que estamos considerando
cuando hablamos de la unidad de vida más
pequeña hablamos de la célula mientras
que un ser humano se acerca a los 2
metros
una célula tiene un diámetro de 100
micrómetros visto desde la perspectiva
del ser humano una célula es cercana a
una diezmilésima parte de su tamaño y
sin embargo suceden muchas cosas aquí
los seres humanos crecemos y tal vez
tengamos bebés y las células harán lo
mismo
crecerán y tendrán bebés también o dicho
de otra manera se someten a una división
celular en el siguiente par de vídeos
vamos a hablar de cómo una célula crece
y se divide así que vamos a hacer un
acercamiento
a celular y la vida de una célula puede
describirse por lo que llamamos el ciclo
celular al ciclo celular lo podemos
comparar con las estaciones del año de
la misma manera en que tenemos
estaciones como la primavera o el verano
donde las cosas crecen también tenemos
estaciones como el otoño o el invierno
donde no la célula tiene un tiempo donde
crece y se divide y otro donde no se
divide existen dos estaciones o tipos de
estaciones dominantes de las que
hablaremos aquí tenemos este periodo de
tiempo de aquí que es parecido al
invierno o al otoño donde no tenemos una
división celular pero la célula crece
más a este período donde la célula pasa
la mayor parte del tiempo se le conoce
como interfase la interfase es donde
principalmente tenemos crecimiento
celular pero no división celular
la interfase es donde las células pasan
la mayor parte del tiempo así que la
mayoría de las células vive aquí pero
existe una excepción clave por aquí cuál
crees que sea si dijiste cáncer estás en
lo correcto las células cancerosas
tienen un defecto que causa que quieran
dividirse más de lo que crecen en un
minuto hablaremos con más detalle de
cómo sucede la otra fase principal del
ciclo celular que tenemos aquí es donde
hay una división celular activa y se
llama mitosis a veces se abrevia solo
con una m la mitosis es el tiempo donde
tenemos una división celular activa
ahora bien hay algunas otras fases que
transcurren durante la interfase la
primera parte de la interfase es una
fase de crecimiento
normalmente se abrevia como que uno
como puedes ver aquí que uno es la fase
más grande del ciclo celular por lo que
esta fase abarca la mayor parte de la
vida de una célula y es aquí donde se
producen organelos extras como ribosomas
y también proteínas hacemos proteínas
que serán útiles cuando lleguemos la
división celular justo aquí la célula
tiene opciones si quieres seguir
creciendo y pasar hacia la división
celular avanzará a la siguiente fase que
se llama fase s la s es por la palabra
síntesis de manera más específica
síntesis de adn ya que aquí tendremos la
replicación del adn y es ahí donde
tomamos 23 pares de cromosomas y los
llamamos pares porque la mitad de ellos
vienen de tu madre y la otra mitad de tu
padre
los duplicamos los replicamos para
obtener 46 pares como mencionamos la
mayoría de las células van en esta
dirección sin embargo algunas de ellas
de g1 toman otra dirección por aquí a
una fase que se le conoce como g 0 donde
no hay división celular ya que hay
ciertas células en el cuerpo que no les
gusta dividirse o no tienden a dividirse
podemos pensar como ejemplo rápido en
las neuronas en el cerebro
una vez que el cerebro está formado las
células no necesariamente se dividen más
sólo crecerán podemos decir que este es
el punto final para este tipo de células
no suelen regresar al ciclo celular de
esta manera
pero continuemos siguiendo este ciclo la
siguiente fase del ciclo celular se
llama g2 y es otra fase de crecimiento
celular donde nos preparamos de manera
más directa para la mitosis así que la
célula se prepara para la mitosis en un
par de formas aquí se hacen microtúbulos
que nos servirán para separar nuestras
cromáticas cuando llegue el momento de
la fase pero hablaremos de qué significa
esto en un vídeo por separado para
terminar tenemos nuestra última fase por
aquí que es la mitosis nuestra estación
final del ciclo celular donde las
células se dividen y cuando se dividen
se convierte en dos células cada una de
las células entrará de nuevo a la fase 1
crecerán y producirán organelos y
proteínas extras que finalmente les
permitirán dividirse de nuevo como
puedes ver estas son parecidas a las
estaciones
y el ciclo celular da vueltas y vueltas
a medida que se divide en las células
más y más excepto claro las células que
entran a esta fase
donde no necesitamos más división
celular